Throughout all of our analyses of the pseudo-Facebook user data
set, we've come to learn a lot about our users.
>From their birthdays, to their friend counts, to their friendships
initiated, we've really come to understand their behaviors and how they
use the Facebook platform. But, now I think it's time
for something completely different. In the next couple of segments,
we'll look at another data set, and then we'll return
to this Facebook data set to draw some comparisons Here's Dean
to introduce this new data set, and why we might look at it in the first place.
>> Because of online purchases, credit cards, and loyalty cards, lots of
retail purchase data is associated with
individuals or households, such that there
is a history of purchase data over time. Analysts in industry often mine
this panel scanner data, and economists and other behavioral scientists use
it to test and develop theories about
consumer behavior. We are going to work with a
data set describing household purchases, of five
flavors of Dannon yogurt in the eight-ounce size.
Their price is recorded with each purchase
occasion. This yogurt data set has a quite
different structure than our pseudo-Facebook data set.
The synthetic Facebook data has one row per
individual with that row giving their characteristics and counts of behaviors
over a single period of time. On the other hand, the yogurt data has many
rows per household, one for each purchase occasion. This kind of microdata is
often useful for answering different types of
questions than we've looked at so far.